pâtissant et il ment dont à daniel
prévost de nous faire oublier cette
tristesse avec un jeu fou et donc on ne
quitte pas la maladie pour un adjectif
jean-pierre voilà avec les filles j'ai
un succès fou jean-pierre subissent
alors souhaité à 20 heures alors qu'elle
faisait foi je me trompe de chansons là
vous allez donc jouer maintenant madame
un adjectif vous allez poser des
questions à s'aliène pour découvrir un
adjectif d'accord d'accord voilà alors
un bon moment en perspective avec les
amis allez vous première question alesi
et puis vous sortir le soir
comment répéter aimez vous sortir le
soir
j'adore avez vous avez vous trouvé de
bonne distraction à charleroi
aimez vous les jeux de 20 heures
etes-vous parfois sérieux aux
distractions favorites
quels sont vos distractions favorites
vous sentez vous proche les aliments
vous sentez vous proche des animaux
aimez vous les vacances
s'il vous plaît il ya lieu de souligner
la classe de patrick la bienvenue on
n'en prend pas du pape là ce n'est pas
un jeu fou et pourtant ça commence par
un b et au total il ya cette lettre
alors b et celle d'être brillant vous
croyez ayant là c'est pas tout à fait du
bien madame c'est un objet